all the stuff you see in video games
we're going to show you how to do in
real life
one of the most recognizable figures in
the sports world
there's one name that's synonymous with
skateboarding it's tony hawk
legendary tony hawk tony hawk
i was 14 years old when i went pro the
very first time that i
created a new trick
that was the buzz that was the high that
i chased the rest of my life
skateboarding is a lifestyle a sport
and an art form all at once
in this master class i'm breaking down
foundational skate tricks and some of my
own signature tricks for the very first
time
we're gonna start from the very
beginning the first time you step on the
skateboard
the first step of the ollie is pushing
down on your back foot until the tail
just hits the ground that sends your
boar straight up
it feels magical you did this with your
feet the three types of skateboarding
that we are covering
are street park and verts lizzie armanto
will take you to the next level of
intermediate tricks and park skating and
riley hawk will guide you through
complicated technical street tricks
the key to a mctwist is in the snap
i reach down for my board and i
turn my head immediately snapping it if
you have the snap
you have the grab you have the spin you
can do it it's just one that you didn't
get to see the landing zone the whole
time
[Music]
school was not a pleasant experience
i got picked on a lot and then i skated
when i found skateboarding i found
my voice you don't have to
follow the textbook of exactly how to
live your life
skateboarding can be a great lesson in
your life
a lesson in perseverance a lesson in
self-confidence a lesson in belief
you don't have to be a pro skater but
you can carry these lessons with you
throughout your life in so many other
ways i'm tony hawk and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
[Music]
you